I'm pre-cringing for what is about to happen.
I'm pre-cringing for what is about to happen.   *Oh no, the cringe is coming*
I've been dreading this video,
for the longest time, it may come as a surprise
But, I didn't always used to be this hip and cool and trendy.
NO!!!
There were dark days
before I did YouTube. Long, long, long ago when my name wasn't PewDiePie.
It was just PewDie and if you don't know what I'm talking about, I used to be very active on the anime forums of
Of MyAnimeList and I've recently gotten...
access to my old account from 2007 and we're going to explore it... Together.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Here's my profile.
Thank God, most of it has been deleted. *:( YUSayThatPewds*
Thank God!
I do have 2000 forum posts.
*Pewds dying internally*
Mmm. Let's see what we can find in Pewdiepie.
Oh my god.
Okay, all right
What have we got? Someone made a thread called. There's this gurl
I really like and I responded 'geez stop posting love prob on these forums!'
*laughs at his own joke*
Way to help out Felix! Good job!
Warhammer Age of Reckoning. 'So, this game was released recently is anyone playing it?'
'I'm installing it at the moment :3'
*epic cringe*
'Level 6 now, XD, I'm liking this game already, feels like WoW 2.0'
*wink*
'I'm playing a marauder'
rawr... (Cringing so much that the color on the video broke.)
This is painful oh
I made this thread called polar bear defends itself against raving mad woman
(respekting wamen at its finest)
*the cringe settles in*
Edgy humor!
What is going to happen to you after you die? Wow what if some philosophical thoughts?
I don't mean to your body, but your mind. It's hard to imagine what's going to be like after we die.
I'm pretty sure death is going to be a lot like before we were born. I guess.
My dream, however, is that all my ancestors will be waiting for me in heaven, like it's at the airport.
*sad music*
Th-the early seeds of agnostic athe-atheism was there. Good, good on you Felix.
Oh god. This is painful. This is so painful.
'What do/did you do when you're bored in class?'
Let's see what I said.
FAP
*sad music*
is online dating really okay someone asked and I responded if you look like shit
'is online dating really okay o.O?' someone asked and I responded
'if you look like shit'
(realisation in 3)
(realisation in 2)
(realisation in 1)
Something weird about laughing at jokes that you made
fucking 10 years ago.
'What are your thoughts on incest?' Oh? Oh no ooh?
Oh, don't say it.
Don't say it, Felix.
'don't you mean WINcest?'
No, god damn it, god damn.
I can't do this anymore!
'Super epic important discussion how, how come', as one word, 'when soul and Tsubaki turn into weapons
sometimes they are nude inside and sometimes they have clothes on'
I can't, I fucking can't, man. This, I fucking can't do this. 'How do you cool down after getting angry?'
'Goosfraba'
Adam Sandler references. Good job..
Oh my
great.
Fan fabulous. That is ooo so nice. What a ha ha moment.
Strange things you do while or after watching anime.
*wait for it*
*boop* FAP
Stop with the fap! What the hell is wrong with you!
'the taste of the female gender'
CENSORED!
'What character do you hate that everyone likes? Why?'
'Misa she's awesome'
No, you don't mean that. Felix, you don't mean that ok? You don't mean. You don't understand what you're saying, ok?
Felix. No. Please. This is the worst! I can't.
I can't do it anymore, man. I can't do it. I can't do it.
'What are your dreams? I'm in pursuit of becoming an a renowned graphic designer.'
Well, that didn't work out did it? (thank goodness)
Oh, this is so fu- strange, man.
'A world without males.'
'A world without men would suck so hard just because then I wouldn't exist'
These are like my old Photoshop, holy shit, it's my old
It's my old World of Warcraft character.
Oh man, I was so proud that I had the Hand of Ragnaros.
Oh.
'About Me: I'm a pretty shy guy. lol.'
'I love anime and Photoshop.'
'My favourite ones are pretty dark.'
*re-evaluates life choices*
'NHK Ni Youkoso, Gankutsou' misspelled, 'and Death Note.' Woow.
Death Note is a pretty dark anime, Felix. So edgy. But otherwise, I am a pretty cheerful guy!
As you can see with this picture that I decided to use.
*laughs faintly*
*girks voicebox*
*girking intensifies*
*faint chuckles*
Is that darker than black? oh
Is that 'Darker than Black'?
Oh my god.
So, what else you can do on uh this website was to rate your anime.
Let's see which ones I rated 10.
Code Geass.
It's a pretty fucking good anime.
Clannad? What are you gay?
I mean come on! It's 10 out of 10. It's a good anime!
Death Note? Hell yeah!
Gankutsuou? Hell yeah. Mononoke? Hell yeah. Kanon? Oh, what was that? That mopey- oh my god?
Oh, that's the one! I always mixed that one up with Clannad.
Kanon is...I think, I gave it a 9. You know what?
Masterpiece!
Update!
Kanon. Oh my god.
*short girk*
Planets nine (?) Planetes was great.
That's a great anime. I still agree with most of these.
Ah, Full Metal Panic.
That was the shit man.
Baccano!
Oh my god. *lol dat voice though*
Alright, which one did I late rate the lowest?
Hotaru no Haka.
Oh, fuck yeah.
It's like a masterpiece movie.
It's just so depressing. I can't stand it.
It's supposed to not glorify war and it shows how bad the the Second World War-
Where was the Second World War?
Yeah, it shows. How bad it is in a realistic way, but man?
It just made me feel so shit that I was like
'I can't watch it'. It's like, it doesn't it does not deserve an average review. It's an, it's an amazing piece.
I gave Neon Genesis Evangelion
a 7.
*slight tint laugh*
The more I think about this anime the more I love it.
I would definitely give it at least an 8 today, maybe a 9. You know what?
Masterpiece!
I was too young. I was too young and too dumb.
Love Hina.
Oh my god.
I can't. I can't. I can't do this anymore.
I have this constant cringe face on when I'm doing this. This is fucking goddamn it.
Last ones I updated was...
I don't even remember watching these.
My favorite character, Yagami Light.
Hell Yeah!
Still is.
Sho Minamimoto. That's from that game. What was it called?
Fuck, I don't remember.
"So zetta slow!"
I used to love math at the time so and he was like a math freak the character or whatever.
So, I thought it was cool.
Is that my email address?
flex89?!
You know me, flex! Mister flex89?
What happens if we search flex?
flex 89 no no no no no no no no no no no no no, but that the put the bet no
I say, no! Well. I think it's a good time to end it there. Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'm sure we all have some embarrassing things from our past that is now stored online
forever and I'm sure in the future I will look at the PewDiePie channel and just cringe at everything.
But uh, you know what? You know what, fuck it. I'm gonna go and say it. Yes. I watch anime.
What are you gonna do about it? I'm proud, god damn it. I don't care what you say. *flauncing it like its hot*
I'm proud. I watch anime and I'm proud.
So, if you don't like it, you can go. Bye. Thank you for watching this video. I hope me sharing all this was worth it.
I'm gonna go and uh...
* sad music *
cringe in a corner. And, I'll see you guys next time. Thanks for leaving a like and subscribing and as always squad fam out.